So to quickly summarize,
we learned about image transformations,
not just about image filtering.
Remember, we talked a lot
about how to do warping in
things like even when we
played around with panoramas.
This is some of the foundations
that we're going to use.
We're going to talk about morphing,
but we're going to come back and
use these, not just image filtering,
but image transformations and warping
to help us do the kinds of computational
photography that we are interested in.
We basically looked at all kinds
of transformations, rigid,
projective transformations of images.
And we actually kind of
looked at what parameters and
how to do this simple types
of things using matrices.
If anybody's curious,
more, more detail exists on chapter
2 of the Rick Szeliski book.
I look it up.
And also, I just, of course, as usual,
relied on other people's slides to
generate the slides that you saw.
More information will be
available on the website.